today's question is should college
athletes get paid
I'm Patrick medieval your host of value
tainment weekly and when you think about
this question here where the college
athletes should get paid or not there's
two different sizes to the argument one
side they shouldn't because the
scholarship is already a way of them
getting paid right and so if we do pay
them they're going to be spoiled it
won't put as much effort to play then on
the other side it's a business if the
NCAA is making money they should as well
I got four points to cover with you then
an idea at the end point number one the
NCAA last year generated 11 billion
dollars in revenues according to mark
Edelman 11 billion dollars only two
sports made more money than the NCAA
that's the Major League Baseball and the
NFL NCAA made more money than NBA and
NHL the president of NC double-a made
1.7 million dollars last year which he
should because he generated revenues
part number two is a law passed back in
1972 it's called title nine the purpose
of title nine is to not discriminate
against different sports so if I'm
playing college football or basketball
or tennis or gymnastics or track I
should one get more scholarship because
football is more important tennis and
it's also a discrimination against men
and woman so the scholarship should be
treated equally but here's the thing
that in 1972 under law passed a lot of
things have changed from 1972 till today
a company came out of 1917 I that
completely revolutionized everything
that company's name is ESPN it turned a
college football coach making 65
thousand dollars failure into a
celebrity now getting paid 5 million
dollars you're getting endorsements a
whole different story it turned viewers
into college football fans college
basketball fans it turned them into
these fans of these sports and it became
a very big business and on the other
side is back in 1972 when title nine
came out when you think about mba Major
League Baseball NHL NFL you've got to
know that most professional athletes
back then had a full-time job on the
side you don't hear athletes today that
play professional sports that have
part-time jobs on the side they did back
then point number two is the fact that
title nine maybe needs to be relooked at
number three there's a big contradiction
between title nine and point number
three because title nine is about
discrimination we shouldn't
yet you know point number three when you
think about academic scholarship and
athletic scholarship is totally there's
a discrimination there because I could
have gone an academic scholarship I got
a 4.3 GPA I'm not a Toledo and Arizona
State picks me up I'm a very attractive
beautiful model I go to Arizona State
University Maxim contact me and says we
want to do photo shoot with you because
you submit at your pictures your
beautiful wanna pay you forty thousand
dollars great that person can get paid
yet and at the yet an athletic
scholarship they can't how does that
make any sense of what academic is more
important in athletic so there is
somewhat of a discrimination there so
why should not a collegiate athlete get
paid on an endorsement they're getting
with nike reebok adidas under armour why
should they not get paid why can't an
athlete that place for university go
make five hundred dollars in a day doing
autographs that that doesn't make any
sense they should as well because that's
their brand to help generate some kind
of revenue standpoint over for if the
NCAA doesn't figure out a way to pay
them they're going to pay them anyways
I've spoken to some people in the
business that said this is not a big
deal to college coaches or universities
because they find ways to get the
athletes money here's typically how it
works they'll tell the kid to go do
security job or go do a waiting you know
whatever it is they'll do something on
the side and they'll send somebody to go
work that valet and that person driving
by will give one hundred thousand dollar
tip you know what you can do you can
discriminate me against giving somebody
a tip what's your law against it you
can't really control it so the kid got a
tip it is what it is so that kind of
stuff happens we've heard it many times
long list of athletes that that's
happened to so unless if they figure out
a way to stop that this law is going to
constantly be broken because these kids
going to find ways to get monies and
other people are going to find wish to
pay them to stick on with that
University so my idea at the end is this
here's my idea one let's figure out a
way where these athletic scholarships
can get money on the side with their
endorsements or autograph signing and
different kind of things that they do
and on top of that is if you're the
university you get a student that
decides to come to your school maybe
give them a bonus structure I'm an
athlete decides to go to Texas A&M tell
me in three years after being with you
if I hit XYZ numbers you're going to
give me eight hundred
thousand dollars at the end or million
eight because of the company made this
much money and you're going to give me a
million eight on that or three hundred
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars or some kind of money that maybe
I'm not getting that money early on at
18 19 years old when i'm playing for the
college team maybe it's going to be a
little bit longer so if I'm college
basketball I'm willing to stay for years
and get my four year degree rather than
going to and be right off the bat but
there are ways to still incentive I the
players I've wanted to stick around it's
my message the weekend please be sure to
subscribe to this channel and more
importantly I want to hear from your
thoughts points you agreed and disagreed
with and maybe some ideas on how we can
get some of these college athletes to
start getting paid properly
you